in the meantime people are being
conditioned for a different way of
looking at things and
you know we've got two years now where
people have spent time and i don't i
don't think this is the same in the
united states but here in australia
in almost every state as i'm aware of it
people are required to check in using a
qr code wherever they go so if you go to
fill up your car with petrol you bring
your phone and you scan the qr code and
you check in and your data then gets
registered in a central database that is
held by the government and then when you
leave
you know you walk out you go to the next
shop you do the same thing so for
example people that have been christmas
shopping might have qr code checked into
10 shops in a day and a half
and then the idea is that of course if
someone's covered positive in that area
you get notified and you know into
quarantine you go sometimes into one of
these many hotels that we'll talk about
as well i don't think that's a
phenomenon the united states has
experienced but here in australia people
are now used to it they look for the
code
and the conditioning to accept this kind
of
soft power totalitarianism is now firmly
getting ingrained in australia's dna and
i think that's really worrying i'm
worried that people aren't more worried
about it frankly i mean there are there
are some that are but people like myself
who make these statements get accused of
being
um you know sort of conspiracy theorists
or whatever you might call
but i think the trajectory on this if
it's not arrested is really bad i worry
about this sort of persuasive social
credit style system that we can see
coming in
um and there's a number of examples of
that south australia in fact my home
state the health bureaucracy here are
the the authors of the home quarantine
app which is a
in my view a dreadful piece of software
which sits on your phone
and the rationale for it was that
instead of being quarantined somewhere
else you can buy your freedom by
agreeing to sign up to this app
and
it contacts you three times a day it
requires you to show a picture of your
face or live stream your face it takes
the gps data from that it triangulates
that information and sends it back to
police headquarters
and confirms that you're at home where
you said you'd be at home
um and if you're not then you get a
knock on the door from the police now
people seem to have accepted that in
this country as being oh well that's
terrific that means i don't have to go
into a midi hotel which is a detainment
facility here
and it's sort of almost a way of
buying your freedom back well you know i
would say to that
my freedom is not something the
government gives me it's it's you know
as it should be in the united states and
as it should be here it's it's an
inalienable right
so we've become very conditioned to
accepting the unacceptable over the last
two years and i think that's really the
the difficulty we're going to face is
winding that back and winding back these
ideas from a bureaucracy that never has
to face up to an electorate nobody who
came up with that idea is ever going to
have to justify it in front of a ballot
box
well you're absolutely right that in the
united states the government is not
allowed to track your every move using
your phone only google has that
right um
i mean i i'm joking of course but google
has effectively taken that right and we
have been conditioned to just simply uh
accept it and so this is you know
another bigger step and i must tell you
that just hearing about the idea that oh
by the way your phone has the ability to
detect whether it's actually your face
because of course your phone does have
that ability and your phone knows
exactly where on earth it is and that
does mean that somebody who avails
themself of the privilege of knowing
whether or not you are at home is uh in
a position to check up on you and yeah
that sounds
like a brand new high-tech kind of
totalitarianism for which we do not have
an exact historical precedent but oh my
god here it comes yeah and of course
it's been sold to the people of south
australia is aren't you proud you know
your local health bureaucracy has
created this wonderful software look at
what the public service can do
but of course we know that that would
have required
you know a separate budget line into the
department it would have required hiring
staff it requires that fifedom to build
and it requires
then a massive massive step to go back
to a time where you didn't have those
resources around you and what we're
seeing in australia of course is this
drift into big government and i think
one of our problems here is that we do
think as australians i think more than
we should um the government can solve
our problems and that's probably one of
the lines where we've drifted from um
you know the united states uh i think
has a much different view of it i mean
we had a series of bushfires in this
country a year and a half ago two years
ago and
the incessant line was why is the
government fixing this i mean these are
natural disasters
but the australian idea in many ways
sadly is that government should fix
these things and and we've become
indelibly marked with the thumbprint of
big government in this country and i and
i and i think that's as concerning as as
anything we have
we don't have a bill of rights here
there's that was i said an entirely
different discussion for whether or not
that's a good thing or a bad thing um
but what it has done is highlighted some
of the deficiencies in our system the
system of federation that's allowed the
states as we described earlier to hold
powers in their own little hand
to block off their borders to travel and
to do what they've done but then also
this issue of the individuals rights and
um that's a big that's a big can of
worms we probably aren't going to open
today but but
you know we're starting to see the
fruits of those those decisions back in
1901 in australia
so there are a number of differences
that uh are becoming clear
one just a structural difference is that
there's an inversion in your system from
the american system where your states
are more powerful than your federal
government
and that of course is at least part of
the explanation for why some australians
are looking out their window and saying
this is all made up in some sense i
don't get it entirely because presumably
every australian has access to michael
gunner and they can listen to him say
his you know his deranged ranting and
his punishing of the unvaccinated and
they can infer that the
the
unrest that they are seeing in uh in
melbourne is about something so they
should be able to put two and two
together but nonetheless i suppose a
certain kind of
sampling of the environment around you
if you're in a state that uh isn't
engaged in uh draconian measures at the
same level might be reassuring
whereas there are parts of
your country in which uh
things are apparently jaw-dropping
including the government checking on you
to see whether
you've gone home
even though at some level as has been
true throughout the pandemic these
measures don't make a lot of sense
epidemiologically
right
it's not obvious that you you know going
out to take a hike or a walk with your
dog is a threat to anybody right so you
know that's right that's right and look
even those things have been restricted
in australia over the last two years
we've have even in this state where we
haven't had as many lockdowns as as the
state of victoria has but we've had them
here where
you know there's been directives on
going out and getting some exercise in
the fresh air in a park with nobody
around you and you would have seen all
of those images of people in in new
south wales which is further eastern
state that's the the state which is the
capital is sydney
where police have been telling people to
move on on bondi beach sitting on a
beach on their own with nobody around
them and and that is the very nature of
the you know the draconian nature there
is no
room for
common sense in that scenario it just
happens
and look there are so many other
examples as well i mean i talked a
little bit before about this concept of
the media hotel and i don't that's
that's something which i don't think
americans
have experienced thankfully but um this
this
i suppose drift into quarantining and
quarantining at home quarantining in old
hotels and quarantining of course in
these quarantine camps as well
is something that australians have
become too
i suppose familiar with in too short a
period of time we have um hotels here
which have basically been repurposed for
two years they're just standard hotels
in the middle of the city here in
adelaide the capital city of south
australia there are about three one of
them is an old apartment block but
they're basically
hotels that have a big metal fence
around them police walking around down
the bottom
and people who've mostly come from
overseas and are doing their 14 days
quarantining or seven or depending
whatever the dictator of the day is
and
they are like little prisons and i mean
people
in this country roll their eyes at that
suggestion those who don't who aren't
worried about what's going on but the
reality is anytime your liberty is
restricted um that's a bad thing it
doesn't matter if you're doing it in a
five-star hotel or if you're behind bars
in a maximum security prison the reality
is as soon as you can't leave your front
door for fear of
penalty you are
locked down your liberty is restricted
so we're seeing that time and time again
um we also have governments now having
gone through that experience as a way of
dealing with quarantining and lockdowns
expanding that out now into this concept
that i know has made a lot of media in
the united states of um of quarantine
facilities they use they try not to use
the word camps but the reality is
they're large transportable units
they're popping up over the country
we've got the major one in the northern
territory where mr gunner is the chief
minister
which is called howard springs that made
a bit of news a month or so ago with a
young lady who
was put into that facility simply for
the crime of walking with someone who
alongside someone who who had covert she
was
captured on a local cctv camera the
person i think was pushing a motorbike
and had therefore had a license plate
there which was recognizable
the contact tracing system identified
her and then identified this lady she
got a knock on the door from the police
and off she went for two weeks in this
facility having never tested positive
for covert so um i want to ask you about
that though
um
this sounds like and i must say it's not
totally unprecedented i know that this
exists in the u.s in a form most
americans are probably not familiar with
but it sounds to me
like she was effectively
convicted of a crime
and sentenced to an admittedly short
sentence in what is effectively a prison
without a court having been involved is
that right yeah that's exactly right and
it's not it's not too long about a draw
i mean many would say that's overstating
it
but the reality is there is no right of
review if you've been charged with a
crime um you have appeal rights and you
have all of those here because of the
nature and the way in which these
schemes have been so you have none and
and so you are certainly i mean and i
think as i said
that home quarantine app that i
described is a much more draconian
measure than you would get for
um you know an offender who's been
sentenced to
home detention you know we would have a
home detention bracelet here under our
legal system um there's never been a
requirement to make people use biometric
facial data and gps's as far as i'm
aware anyway
so i think i think although it does seem
sometimes those
comparisons are unfair i think there's a
it's a very slippery slope and it's a
question of what you become accustomed
to as a society
australians have become in my view too
accustomed to these restrictions on
liberty and in fact one of the things
that's been really alarming has been the
extent to which australians have become
accustomed to it
and
you know i think that this is why the
message needs to be out there we know
that from from polling that's been done
i did a bit of polling from my own
office that in south australia somewhere
between 30 and 40 of people felt
compelled to get a vaccination so we've
effectively bullied
hundreds of thousands of people we're a
state of about 1.7 million so on those
numbers we have effectively bullied and
coerced that many people into getting a
medical treatment that they weren't
otherwise going to want to so people
have become very accustomed to doing
what they're told
and if that isn't alarming then i i just
don't know
what is
well you're doing an admirable job
you're bending over backwards not to be
alarmist right you you keep cautioning
me about the possibility of over
interpreting these things and and my
feeling is
we shouldn't get uh
too bent out of shape about the
imprecision you know is it a detention
camp
well i don't know
it doesn't really matter if it's a
detention camp the question is if it's
not a detention camp is there some other
thing that we're aware of that it is
more like than a detention camp and if
the answer is not obviously then the
question is all right why are we playing
around with something that is plausibly
a detention camp right can we look back
at history at the number of times that
we've done this and how we felt about it
afterwards and say
you know what are we doing as i've said
on on my podcast what are we doing
in this part of the library right why
are we looking at the nazis and the
nuremberg trials and saying well how
precisely you know applicable are these
standards and the answer is it doesn't
precision has nothing to do with it the
fact that we're even looking at the
nuremberg code and saying hey wait a
minute what are we up to here tells us
we've found ourselves in territory we
don't want to be in and
you know it's also i keep reminding
myself
true that we are doing this
this isn't smallpox right i have never
been somebody who has minimized the
danger of covid in fact i was very early
on the idea that covid was more
dangerous than it appeared that the case
fatality rate did not capture the damage
that the disease does and that we should
all be very cautious about it but that
said
it is not that lethal a disease and for
you australians it's even less lethal
because you don't have a tremendous
problem with it you have a much better
controlled problem and yes those who are
in favor of these measures might argue
that your excellent control of it is the
result of these measures on the other
hand it may have to do with your
proximity to the equator and therefore
levels of vitamin d you're being an
island you know there are a lot of
factors that contribute but nonetheless
the question is
you've got these extreme measures that
in some sense have no parallel other
than
uh many of the worst chapters of history
at the same time you have a disease that
while yes it's not the flu is also not
so extreme that it's obvious we should
turn upside down
all of the hard one rights in the west
uh in order to control it especially
when controlling it has been something
we've obviously failed at
[Music]